MALE SPEAKER: It's a
great pleasure for me
to introduce Betsy Brown
Braun to you guys today.
Betsy's a child development
and behavior specialist,
a parenting consultant, a
multiple-birth parenting
consultant, and the founder
of Parenting Pathways, Inc.
I think most people
probably know her
primarily as an author.
That's how I first
learned about Betsy.
She has two books, "Just
Tell Me What to Say"
and "You're Not the Boss
of Me," both bestsellers.
We have some copies of each here
today, so hopefully most of you
got a chance to get one.
They're great books.
They're really practical
tips and scripts
for every sort of
parenting situation
you might find yourself in.
In fact, I think
that's literally
one of the subtitles
for one of the books.
She's also been involved
in elementary and childhood
education for over 40
years, is a mom to triplets.
Right, Betsy?
Yeah.
My wife and I first met
Betsy almost two years ago
after reading her books.
We found out that she's actually
local, lives in the Pacific
Palisades, and she leads groups.
She leads parenting group
sessions, seminars, and also
individual parenting sessions.
And so my wife and I attended
a couple of the seminars.
One of them was called
"Elementary School,
Here I Come."
And just been an
invaluable resource
in part of the process for
getting our five-year-old ready
for kindergarten
later this year.
And then we doubled
down and went
to the safety seminar,
which is also great.
Still trying to get
into discipline.
Every time I've tried to
register for the discipline
seminar, it's been sold out.
So, I'm hopeful that this
will help me to get a spot--
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: April 29th.
MALE SPEAKER: --at the
next discipline seminar.
OK, good.
So without any
further ado, I'm going
to introduce Betsy
Brown Braun, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Thank you.
I'm so not a clapping
sort of person.
They wanted me to
stand on stage.
I don't do that either.
I'm a mom, and I'm
among my people.
So I like to speak
to you that way.
I was happy when Dan
asked me to come and speak
to you, because this is an
organization that I have
a lot of-- organization,
workplace-- about which I have
a lot of preconceived notions.
And I imagined
you'd all be wearing
those-- like he has on--
and that you'd all be,
a lot of pens in your pockets,
and all that sort of thing.
But I'm glad to see
perfectly normal people here.
So let me ask you a question.
I really want to
ask each of you,
but we don't have time,
how old your kids are
and where they go to school.
So am I correct if I make the
assumption that the youngest
kids we have-- we probably have
some infants, and toddlers,
and nursery schoolers.
And elementary schoolers.
Do we have any teens?
There you go.
Young company, young people.
Got it.
OK, so at least I know-- by the
way, thank goodness for you--
and at least I know
what my audience is.
Let me ask you this
question, though.
Did any of your parents
go to parenting seminars?
Right?
Go to bed, now!
It was that sort of thing.
Life has really changed.
Aside from all the Google
stuff, life has really changed.
From a sociological
perspective, life
has changed because people are
getting married much older.
People are having babies
before they get married.
People have different
kinds of relationships.
The definition of family
continues to evolve.
Very often, more often
than not, both parents
have a career going before
they begin a family.
Or at least one parent does.
And you young people today
have a taste for what you want.
And you have goals, and
this is what you plan to do.
I laugh about this
because I actually
have parents who come to visit
me and see me about schools.
This really happened.
A couple sat down on
my couch and said,
just tell me the nursery
school that my kid should
go to so I can get him into
the best elementary school,
so I can get him into
the best high school,
so I can get him into-- fill in
the blank, whatever college you
want your kid to go to.
And I laugh, and I
think, yeah, right.
And by the way,
they're just going
to come home and live with you.
He's going to come home
and live with you anyway,
because no one's getting jobs.
You're not from
India, so forget it.
But what's happened
is, parents, you
have a clear taste-- you
have a clear idea of what
you want for your kids,
what you hope will happen.
And parenting gets attacked
like it's another career.
You do everything
you need to do,
and you come to see
Betsy for school.
And you're having
trouble with this,
and you come and see Betsy.
I didn't have a Betsy.
I was 22 years old
when I got married.
Wouldn't you plotz if your
kid got married at 22?
Crazy.
I wasn't even done
growing at 22.
And I had my kids
when I was 30, which
is still considered young.
Which doesn't make
sense biologically,
because we're already
going downhill after 25.
Oh, that's another seminar.
Forget it.
OK.
So this is as much
about the parent
as it is about the child.
Parenting, what I do, child
development and behavior
specialist.
It's not really about the child.
It's really about you.
You have so much to do
with how this goes for you.
We live in this
new era where there
is a new sport
that is king, and I
call that sport
competitive parenting.
And we all giggle when I say
that, but you know it's true.
We do live in that.
We all have goals for our
kids, but we're not really sure
how to make them happen.
I think it's incredibly
ironic that when you're
pregnant we say, you're
expecting, because-- someone
laugh, because that's really
good-- because your baby is
born and you're expecting.
You're expecting this
one will be an artist.
And this one will
be a soccer player.
be good at tap.
And this one will do
underwater basket weaving.
And you've got all these plans
you're expecting for your kid.
And then, your child
is born, and it's
like, oops, I guess he
won't be playing basketball.
Or oops, I guess he'd
better play basketball,
or whatever it would be.
We don't want our kids
to miss out on anything.
We would be you, by the way.
I'm done.
My kids are 36, and
they're fully cooked.
Actually, I take that back.
Because what I really know
now-- I'm a granny of three.
Each of my kids is married.
Each has one baby.
And I know that there is no
expiration date on parenting.
It just doesn't ever stop.
Different, but doesn't stop.
So I take that back.
But you don't want your kids
to miss out on anything.
We want them to all
have the options
to do whatever it
is they need to do.
And as a result of that,
we make sure that they
can do everything.
You take your two-year-old
to soccer skills classes.
By the way, why?
But you do.
Or it's not really soccer.
It's ball skills.
Why?
They have no eye-hand.
What are you doing
with a two-year-old?
Or we now sign kids
up for soccer at four.
Why?
They can't do team sports.
They're like a little beehive
when they run around the field.
It's crazy, right?
They have art.
They have yoga.
They have all this stuff
for these little bitty kids
when all they really need
to be doing is playing.
Because that's what children
need when they're young,
because play is the
work of childhood.
It is the business of childhood.
It's more important,
given safety and health,
than anything else.
But I digress.
So it's kind of like
a race, this becomes.
Hurry, get my kid into this and
this and this nursery school.
And it's crazy.
You know what I'm talking about.
And what happens is that we're
so busy scheduling our kids'
lives, giving them all the
things we think they're
supposed to do, that
we're kind of forgetting
to look at the child and
see where the child comes
into this.
And we're not
necessarily doing what
that particular child needs.
Here's what hasn't changed.
Maybe parenting, the way in
which we parent, has changed.
But what hasn't changed
is what children need.
Nothing has changed
in that realm.
Kids need to feel safe.
They need to feel connected.
They need to feel that they
are significant in your life.
They need to feel that
they are part a whole team,
and that that whole
team is a safety net.
Of this, I am abundantly sure
and clear that kids need that.
They also need-- and this
hasn't changed, ever.
Socrates would say the same.
They need to have
the traits, or shall
we say skills, the
traits of character
that enable them to
grow up and become
self-reliant, and
resilient, and honest,
and good citizens in the world.
That won't happen by accident.
There are actually
traits that we
need to instill in our children.
And that's kind of what this,
my second book, is about.
And I will talk to you
about the difference
in the books in a minute, but
that's why I wrote that book.
What else hasn't changed
is child development.
Children still develop
in the same way
that they have always developed.
There is a particular path.
Now, I fully believe that all
of you have kids who are gifted.
You live in West LA.
It kind of goes
with the property.
You have a gifted child.
I know.
But the fact remains,
that all hu--
you'd be surprised how
many people call and say,
kind of shyly, well,
my kid is gifted.
And I want to laugh.
My kid's really smart.
And I say, let me guess,
he's gifted, right?
It's your job to think
your kid is gifted.
And he might be.
2% of the population is.
The fact remains that all
human beings, when born,
have to go through a series
of predictable stages
of development in every single
realm, one before the other,
one foot in front of the
other, in order to grow up.
Cognitively, socially,
emotionally, physically,
large muscle, and small muscle.
They must go through them.
You don't get to just start your
kid here and say, OK, buddy,
run.
You've seen it.
It doesn't work that way.
And while it may happen
at different times
for different kids, the
progression remains the same.
I laugh when I see
parents-- there
was this thing a while ago
where parents were doing flash
cards for kids, babies, holding
up the word cow every one
minute, every hour.
Cow, cow, cow.
And pretty soon, the kid
looks up and goes, cow.
Whatever, he can't even
talk, but he's going, cow.
As if that's going to
mean the child is reading.
There's so much that has
to happen, cognitively,
developmentally,
in a child for him
to get to any one
of these stages.
But we're so busy planning
their little lives
that they don't get to
pass through those stages.
Because we're too busy
doing underwater basket
weaving when they should
be climbing trees.
The child has to be in balance.
Everything needs to
develop and grow.
Because we want our
kids to be in balance.
Here's a good example.
I've been the director
at many schools.
I opened a very large school.
I've done a lot of
teaching, all that stuff.
And once I had a child-- I was
directing a nursery school.
Nursery school and preschool
are the same thing.
I just don't like
the word preschool.
I had a child.
Mother came in.
He was three.
And she said, Betsy,
my child is really--
AUDIENCE: Gifted?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN:
Yeah, definitely.
And I said, great, I'm
sure you're really happy.
Well, I really want him to
be in the four-year-old class
because he's really--
AUDIENCE: Gifted?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Yeah.
I looked at this woman, and
I thought, I am not stupid.
I'm not going to
argue with this woman.
I don't care.
I'm going to let her
fall on her face.
So after she was convincing
me that are kid was gifted,
I said, you know what,
let's give it a try.
So I took this
little, tiny, pencil
of a three-year-old,
this sweet little monkey,
and he went into
the four-year-olds.
Now, how many of you
have four-year-olds?
OK, four-year-olds, right?
The f-ing fours.
They're monsters.
[IMPERSONATING MONSTER]
They're crazy, four-year-olds.
Three-nagers, f-ing
four-year-olds.
You got it.
OK.
So this little boy goes into
the four-year-old class,
looks around, crawls
under the table.
Second day, he comes
to school, plays
a little while, crawls
under the table.
We went through
approximately seven
or eight school days of
crawling under the table.
And then he came out a little
while, but the end of the story
is, three weeks later, the
mother came to me and said,
I'm wrong.
He should be with
the three-year-olds.
Ah.
Because socially, and
emotionally, and physically,
he wasn't ready.
It doesn't matter how
gifted your child is.
Children need to be in balance.
And this is not
something you can hurry.
Every child is born
with a timetable,
and we've got to move them along
in the way they're supposed
to move-- he is
supposed to move.
Let's talk for a minute about
that connectedness thing
I referred to when I talked
about what kids need.
It sounds really obvious, right?
It sounds simple.
Well, of course, your
kid's connected to you.
Came from my body.
He loves me.
I love him.
Not automatic,
and not so simple.
And what's so important
about connectedness?
Well, let me say that when
a child feels connected--
feels connected--
to his parents,
when he feels that he is
significant in his parents'
lives, when he
feels like he makes
a difference in your life,
he's going to be a good kid.
It's as simple as that.
Not really.
In order to put your kids
in a position of wanting
to cooperate, in wanting
to do what you ask,
in wanting them to not do what
you don't want them to do--
because we know discipline is
either, don't do that, or do
do that.
Kind of the end of
the story there.
The child needs to feel that
he and you are connected.
Because that feeling
activates in him
a desire to be a good kid.
But if you're on opposing teams,
when you're on opposite teams,
the impulse to fight
is so strong in a child
that he's going
to go against you.
And that's activated.
We all have that.
We all have the
fight-or-flight thing
in our sweet little brains,
in our primitive brains.
And that's there in
your children, too.
When your child feels
connected, the opposite happens,
and the impulse to
please you is activated.
So how do we encourage that
sense of connectedness?
Because it's not
just going to happen.
You actually already know the
answer to this, presumably,
because you all have kids.
Or I'm assuming everybody
who's here has a kid.
First of all I say, spend
time with your child.
And that sounds so silly
because, of course,
you spend time.
But you're all here.
So that means you have this
much time at this end of the day
and this much time at
this end of the day.
And you also have your
houses, and your laundry,
and your family,
and your cooking,
and whatever else
you have to do.
So it's really hard to
spend time with your kids.
And you don't get to just
spend time on the weekends.
This is like putting
money in the bank.
Drip, drip, drip.
The drip method of parenting.
There needs to be
something every day.
And what I'm saying is,
do fun stuff together.
Don't do stuff where you're
telling him what to do,
or you're taking
care of errands,
or you're checking
things off the list.
Kids feel attached to you
when you're doing stuff
where you're not commenting,
criticizing, judging,
directing, telling
them what to do.
Sit down on the floor
and say, oh, LEGOs.
Or do stickers, or play
with dolls or puppets.
But just be with your child,
because that message says,
I want to be with you.
You are important to me.
One of the mistakes I think
parents make, by the way,
is trying to fit the
child into your world.
And I mean this for when
your kids get older.
You need to fit into
your kid's world.
If you don't know anything about
LEGOs, you better find out.
If your kid loves baseball,
and you've never--
you need to get into it.
You need to join your
child in his world.
It's not his job to join
you in your world, yet.
OK.
Have real conversations
with your children.
Now I realize that only a couple
of you have four-year-olds,
and so there's
probably-- when you're
talking about how you
talk to kids when they're
teenagers, that's a lot easier.
But I'll tell you the
story of a client of mine
who had a little boy, age
seven, who said to her, Mom,
you never talk to me.
And she looked at him and said,
what are you talking about?
I always talk to you.
He said, no, you
never talk to me.
She said, don't be silly.
I talk to you all the time.
He said, you don't.
You don't talk to me.
She said, what are
you talking about?
I talk to you.
We're talking now.
He said, no, you
don't talk to me
like the way you talk to Dad.
He said, when you
talk to Dad-- I
know what you're imagining here.
I don't mean that.
When you talk to Dad,
first Dad says something,
and then you say something,
and then Dad says something,
and then you say something.
And he said, yeah.
She said, well, that's
having a conversation.
He said, we don't
have a conversation.
You're just always telling
me what I have to do next.
I thought that was
pretty heady stuff.
That's what I mean,
connect with your child.
Stop directing and
telling, we got to do this.
Hurry up.
We're going to be late.
Get to school.
Get to the babysitter.
We need to connect
with our children.
They need to feel like what
they say is important to you,
makes a difference,
that you hear them.
Your job is to be a container
for your child's feelings.
So when your child comes
to you and tells you
something, most people, men--
sorry men, but it is true.
When your child comes
and tells you something,
you try to fix it.
Because that's what guys do.
And women-- less so, but when
it's your child, we do it.
Ladies, when you sit
down with a partner,
and you say, oh my god, let me
tell you what happened today,
da, da, da, da.
And your partner says,
well did you try this?
And I want to say,
no, just listen.
Don't talk.
Just listen to
what I have to say.
Your kids are kind
of the same way.
They don't always
want to be told
what they should have done,
or what they should try.
They just need to get it out.
So listen to your child
when he comes to you
and wants to talk to
you about anything.
I don't care if
he's two, and he's
talking about the
birdie that just went by
or the boo-boo he has.
Just encourage more talk.
Because I can promise
you, when your child
gets to be 11 and 12, he's
going to go in that cave.
And you won't see him
for a long, long time.
He's hibernating until he's 17.
That's when they come out.
It's amazing.
Treat your children
with respect.
I am often, always, asked.
Yesterday, when I did a show
for the Hallmark program, that
was one of the
questions I was asked.
Well, how do you instill
respect in a child?
My first answer
to that is, well,
do you treat your
child with respect?
Do you speak respectfully
to your child?
Maybe, maybe not.
I can't tell.
I don't know you.
But I've heard an awful
lot of disrespect.
Just recently at Ralph's
Market in the Palisades,
a woman turned to her son and
said, what's your problem?
And I just stood there
thinking, did you
really yell that at your child?
First of all, he doesn't
know what his problem is,
and you're being irritating.
And, oh my gosh,
what a mess that is.
I should have given her my card.
Here, see me.
She probably would've
yelled at me.
I would have hated that.
The same respect you show your
child will come back to you.
Talk to him with respect.
Talk to him in just the way
you want him to talk to you.
Talk to him the way you
would talk to your friends.
We treat, often, our friends
and our extended family
more kindly and
more respectfully
than we speak to
our own children.
I'm not saying say
please and thank you.
I'm talking about your tone.
I'm talking about how you
relate to a child verbally.
All children-- remember, we're
talking about connectedness
here, so respecting, talking,
listening, being a container.
All children need very
clear limits and boundaries.
We're going to talk
about this later.
Very hard to do,
because you're tired.
It's the end of your day.
Good Lord, it's hard.
I know.
But when you have
limits and boundaries,
and when you follow through,
your children will feel safe,
and they will learn to
trust that you will be there
for them.
The kids who do not have
clear boundaries kept,
who have parents who
do not follow through
on their threats, are the kids
who not only don't feel safe
but often get in
trouble in school.
Just a little thought
I would give you.
There are going to
be difficult times.
be bumps in the road.
There are going to be
challenges to your parenting.
That's what all
of this is about.
And your child is working
really, really hard
to become himself,
whatever that is.
But I can promise you
that becoming yourself
means he's not
going to become you.
He's going to have
to separate from you.
And oftentimes, being
separate from you
means going against what you are
saying, not agreeing with you,
defying you, being disobedient.
One of my kids used
to say to me when
I would use the word
behave, he would say,
Mommy, I'm going to be-not-have.
That was pretty great.
By the way, he turned out OK.
That kid's really an OK kid.
So, this connectedness
will happen
if you don't take their
icky behavior personally.
This is not about you.
It's about your child.
But it is about you, because the
way we respond to our children,
and the way we talk to them,
and the time we spend with them,
feeds our connectedness, feeds
their sense of significance,
and helps them to
be better kids.
Let's talk about my
books for a second,
because that's why I'm here,
just for a quick moment.
This book, "Just
Tell Me What to Say,"
is a book that my
publisher made me
say, we'll put for
two- to six-year-olds.
But the truth be
known, this book
is really for parents
of kids of all ages.
And it deals with
discipline, and food issues,
and sibling issues,
and stuff like that.
And then it's, how do you
talk to your kid about death?
If you have a four-year-old,
you should be there about now.
Four-year-olds all want
to know about death.
How do you talk to
your kids about sex?
They're all going to ask
where babies come from.
You better know
the answer to that.
How do you talk to
kids about earthquakes?
We talked about that.
How do you talk to kids
about serious illness?
Somebody's going to
have something bad.
So this is a very practical
book kind of aimed
at the younger child,
but good for all.
And this is the
book I referred to
before that talked
about inculcating
your kids with character traits.
Let me just say, my books
sound just like me when I talk.
They're not haughty.
They're not terribly cerebral.
They're logical.
It makes sense.
Hands-on tips and scripts.
OK, moving on.
Done with the hard sale.
I think that self-reliance is
one of the most critical traits
we can inculcate in
our kids, of all ages.
Because when a kid
is self-reliant,
he feels good about himself.
When a kid is self-reliant,
he will become resilient.
When a child has a
sense of self-reliance,
he's not so afraid.
The bumps in the road that
happen won't knock him down.
He'll know how to save himself.
I think it's a critical trait.
I was at the airport, which
is one of my favorite places
to observe.
I go to the airport a lot,
because two of my grandchildren
don't live in LA.
So I'm in airports a lot.
And I saw this one
scene-- and I just
loved it-- where a little
girl, probably six or seven,
was walking down the--
what's it called, the thing?
All the way down.
There's a word I can't think of.
Jetway, course way,
one of those words.
Anyway--
And she had her little
Strawberry Shortcake suitcase.
Can you picture it?
One of these things.
She's walking down
with her suitcase.
She also has a doll-- I think
it was an American Girl doll.
You know what I'm
talking about, right?
American Girl doll-- and
her suitcase, and a jacket,
and a pillow.
And she was full loaded, locked
and loaded, walking down.
And she's just
walking right away.
And I'm just giggling
looking at her.
She was adorable.
And her mommy leans back
and says, can I help you?
And she says, no!
And she keeps walking.
I thought, yes, I
like that mommy.
I want to go tell her.
Shortly thereafter, I
was going to Austin,
so it's an interesting crowd.
Oh, you know Austin.
It's the Nerd Bird that flies to
Austin, between Silicon Valley
and Austin.
I digress.
Sorry.
A dad and a mom and
a boy are walking,
and the boy was probably nine.
And nine-year-old
boys-- well, that's
a different presentation.
And he's walking, and
his was a Star Wars case.
And he was walking like this.
One of those things.
And his father was doing one
of those, come on, hurry up.
We're running late.
And every time his
father said something,
another spike grew in his foot.
And he was going so slowly,
was carrying nothing else.
And his father got
really ticked off at him.
He said, oh, just forget it.
I'll get it.
And the father went and
grabbed his suitcase.
And they walked on.
And I thought to
myself, who is going
to become a self-reliant
adult in this group here?
You can see who's
off to a good start.
Self-reliance is
really important.
I want to talk about you
first, and the way you
instill self-reliance.
Then I want to give
you some tips for how
to help your child
to be self-reliant.
One of the sayings for which
I'm known is the following.
Prepare your child
for the path, and not
the path for your child.
Should I say it again?
Prepare the child for the path,
and not the path for the child.
Parents spend a lot of
time preparing the path.
He shouldn't do this.
Wear a jacket.
And taking the rocks
out of the road,
and making sure he doesn't trip.
And don't let him go there.
And in so doing, we actually
undermine our children's
ability to be self-reliant
and to be resilient.
I think it is incredibly
important, because whether you
call it overparenting, or tiger
parenting, or teacup parenting.
Do you know what that is?
Have you heard that one?
Teacup parenting is
when with the child
is held like a
precious China teacup.
We hold him like
this because we don't
want him to fall and break.
Teacup parenting,
helicopter parenting--
it's all the same thing.
You undermine your child's
ability to become self-reliant.
Your job is to help
your child grow
to be a satisfied and
content adult, without you.
I don't say happy because I
don't-- happy is one of those
words.
You're not supposed to be happy.
You're supposed to be OK.
You're supposed to be content.
No one's happy all the time.
That stupid song,
if you're happy
and you know it clap your--
no one's happy all the time.
Supposed to be content.
This is OK.
I'm good.
So if we want our
kids to be that way,
we have to help them to make
their own lives that way.
And in so doing that,
it becomes clear to me
that your real job as a
parent is to talk yourself out
of a job, is to work
yourself out of a job.
I was a school
director, and I knew
I was doing well
as a director when
I could leave the school for a
day or two and know the school
would run really well,
because my teachers were
so competent and self-reliant.
The same should
happen with your kids.
They should know what
to do without you
telling them what to do.
And the truth be known, when
you are not with your children,
they probably do.
When your kids are
not with you, they
become kids you haven't met.
Why is that?
Because your kids save their
worst behavior for the people
whose love they trust the most.
Makes sense when
you think about it.
When you call home
to your parents now,
do you call home and are
lovely and kind and everything
is wonderful?
No.
Oh, Ma, such a bad day.
Adult kids, still
let their parents
get the hairy end of
the lollipop, as we say.
And it starts when
they're very young.
So it's not abnormal,
what's going on.
But the truth of the
matter is that we
should be putting our
kids in a position
that they don't need us.
This is where
mindfulness comes in.
Now mindfulness is
a very hot topic.
I'm sure it's a hot topic
here, as it is everywhere.
We've got lots of people in my
field who are talking about it.
And the reason I'm
bringing this up
is because this isn't
about mindfulness, per se,
because this is about parenting.
But in order to
be the parent whom
you need to be for your child,
you have to parent mindfully.
And sometimes using
mindfulness techniques
will help you not to be
the kind of parent who
shoots from the hip.
In other words, steam
comes out of your ears,
you start screaming,
you use language
you wish you didn't use-- I'm
not talking about swearing,
but just words that
are unkind-- you
don't speak to your
kid respectfully.
We need to use mindfulness
in our parenting,
because your kids are
going to drive you nuts.
If they're not doing it
now, you're on the cusp.
It will happen.
Nobody steers clear of this.
Your kids are going
to frustrate you.
They're going to put
you on the brink.
And all that stuff
is going to happen.
And the way you react
to that behavior
has everything to do with
how and who your child is,
who he will become,
and how he behaves.
You influence that far
more than you know.
You reflect to your child
who you see and who he is.
This is the image
he's going to absorb
and contributes to
his sense of self.
So if you're looking at him and
saying, [INAUDIBLE], whatever.
You're yelling, and screaming,
and giving him all that.
He's looking at
himself as being,
I must not be worthy of much.
My mom's yelling at me.
My dad's yelling at me.
On top of that, we know that
mindfulness and the techniques
therein for grownups
certainly allow
you to control your emotions.
Parents ask me all the time,
what do I do if I get angry?
And I say, well, do I look
like a yoga instructor?
I can teach you a couple things,
but there are many techniques
that we use when we parent
mindfully that will help you.
Parenting mindfully means
controlling yourself.
It means thinking
about what you do.
It means being able to
get yourself into a place
that you can be the kind
of parent you want to be.
To that extent, it's important.
I also want to show you--
I brought this with me
because I grabbed it
at the last minute.
This is a book that I
actually like very much.
I'm selling my books,
not theirs, but oh well.
This is called "Sitting
Still Like a Frog."
And it's by-- I think she
pronounces her name Eline Snel.
And it's a lovely little book
that's actually for kids.
But it's applicable to
adults, too, of course.
And it talks about
exercises in mindfulness
that you will be able
to use with your kids
when they get older.
I'm about to say
something about that.
But I wanted you
to see this book.
It has a CD in the
back with a lady
with a really annoying voice.
I hope it isn't the author's.
But nice ideas, good techniques
you'll be able to use.
The reason I'm showing you
that is because I'm a good guy,
but also because I want
you to know that it is not
reasonable to expect your
children to be mindful,
to use mindfulness techniques
under the age of five or six.
She says five.
I say six.
Why is that?
Because when children
are very young,
they are controlled by a lot
of things, including impulses.
And your impulse will always
trump your desire to be mindful
and to do the right thing.
Kids are subject
to their impulses.
Do you remember-- is
any of you old enough
to know who Porky Pig was?
Ba da ba da ba da ba
da, that's all, folks.
When Porky was a bad little
pig, do you remember,
little angel Porky
would come out over him.
She was in a halo and a
gown, and she would say, yep,
yep, yep, now, Porky,
you be a good little pig.
And at the same time
that would happen,
a devil Porky would
come on the other side.
And he would have a belly, and
cloven hooves, and the ears,
and he would say, [INAUDIBLE],
you be a bad Porky.
And there was this
conflict that went on.
Your kids have angel
and Porkies in them.
And the angel Porky is you,
doing what-- your child has
inculcated you, has
integrated you, as the id
or as the parent who's,
that's the right thing to do.
But the devil Porky
is impulse control.
And they just don't--
he's going to win.
Impulse control is going to win.
So asking a child
to be mindful--
we want to set our kids
up to be successful,
so be careful about asking
him to do these things when
he's a little guy.
He doesn't have the
concentration or the focus.
He can get there.
We tell young kids when they're
angry to do things like blow
out the candles.
And you hold up your
fingers, and they go--
[BLOWING]
Because we know when we
flood our brains with oxygen,
it calms us down.
So that was just a
little aside that I
wanted to talk to you
about about mindfulness.
The other book that I brought--
this is totally non sequitur.
I apologize, but I
don't want to forget--
is a wonderful book called
"Your Fantastic Elastic Brain."
And this is not for
your little bitties.
But this is really for kids in
the 4 and 1/2, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, by this terrific
lady, JoAnn Deak,
who knows all there is to
know about kids, and brains,
and teaching in
the key of brain,
as opposed to what someone
else says you should learn.
And it's a great book that
helps kids to understand
all the anatomy of the brain,
and the different parts,
and helps them understand that
there is actually something
over which they can
have some control.
So I just thought I would drop
that for you as a little treat.
So what's the child's role
in the self-reliance thing?
Well, raising kids is really
about raising parents.
Actually we're not
even raising kids.
We're raising adults.
They're already kids.
So I don't even know
why we call it that.
The child has to pass through
those stages we've discussed.
And every child has a different
time line for doing that.
But every child is born
with a different profile.
Even my three children, two
minutes and 10 minutes apart,
are very different.
Why is that?
Because each child has
a different temperament.
Children are born
with temperament.
Am I talking foreign here?
No?
OK, we good?
Temperament and personality
are two different things.
Your temperament is
the how of what you do.
So it's adaptability, and
flexibility, and intensity,
and energy level, and need for
regularity, and all that stuff.
That's your temperament.
The factory-equipped
model comes out,
that when you're
expecting-- there he comes,
and he got someone's
temperament.
It is inherited.
When temperament
meets environment,
you get personality.
So that one child who is slow
to warm up-- probably a category
you've heard.
We used to use the
"s" word and say shy.
We don't say shy anymore.
It's the new "s" word.
A slow-to-warm-up kid-- that
child is going to be a totally
normal, typical kid at home,
running, talking, playing,
jumping on furniture.
But when that child goes to
school, probably very quiet,
doesn't say anything.
That's when the
teacher says, gosh,
we've never heard your kid talk.
And you say, really?
So that's temperament
becoming different personality
in one environment
or in another.
So every child is born
with that temperament.
He also acquires traits
from living with you.
He absorbs what you do.
He's watching you all the
time, everything you do.
You put something in your
mouth, and your child says,
what are you eating, Mommy?
What is that, Daddy?
They're kind of all up
in you all the time.
They're watching
everything you do.
And there's this whole
new field of epigenetics--
I don't know if you're learning
about that, talking about it,
thinking about it.
It's utterly fascinating--
which is the field that
helps us to understand
that we can actually
change genetic material,
literally, by the environment.
And they've done amazing
studies with twins about that,
and it's utterly fascinating.
So we know that children
can actually change
based on the environment
that they're in.
I mean biologically,
not just behaviorally.
But for all kids, we know this.
In order to grow up,
there are three peaks
that children must climb.
No one can grow up without them.
They need to learn to
tolerate frustration.
tolerate disappointment.
And they need to learn
to delay gratification.
You know in your world,
you have to learn that.
You have to do that.
You're not going to be
the class president.
The playdate's going
to get canceled.
You're not going to get a
new car that you thought
you would get when you
were 16, whatever it is.
But in order to grow
up and to become
a self-reliant, resilient child,
you need to learn those things.
Otherwise you will fall apart.
As the child climbs
these peaks, there
are going to be a lot
of emotions expressed.
And that's where your
mindfulness stuff
is going to step in and help you
to help him to deal and become
aware of his emotions
and how they affect him
when da, da, da da, da.
So there's this delicate
dance that parent and child
do together.
We call that goodness of fit.
You've got your problems, and
your stuff, and your interests,
and the child's problems, and
his stuff, and his interests.
And we've got to figure
out how you dance together.
Not so easy.
One of the incorrect
notions that we have as we
do this dance is
that we're supposed
to protect our children.
We're supposed to shelter
them from disappointment,
or from pain, or
from frustration.
But the truth be told, it
is through experiencing
these very things
that your kids grow
the ability to be in the world.
It's like building immunities.
You got to do it.
So, you know what the
toughest part of your skin is,
by the way?
Any idea?
This isn't a quiz.
AUDIENCE: Your hand?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Your hand?
AUDIENCE: Heel?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Heel's
a really good answer.
Hand wasn't a bad answer,
but heel's really good
because the skin is so tough.
It's a scar.
That's really
interesting, isn't it?
That a scar is the
toughest part of your skin.
And that says it all.
Children need to be hurt
in order to not be hurt.
Dr. Spock, who you really
probably don't remember,
but Dr. Spock had a wonderful
phrase where he said,
"The child who has
not been bandaged
has not been well parented."
Good point, huh?
The trait that's at the top of
my list for helping children,
for putting children
in the position
to be content and
satisfied, is self-reliance.
Because self-reliant
kids grow up
to feel confident, and
competent, and resourceful,
and spontaneous.
And the two critical
points you need
to learn as we talk
about self-reliance,
just for a bit more,
are number one,
you may not hover
over your child.
Hovercraft parents do not
raise self-reliant children.
So you need to back off.
Children need space between you.
The second thing is,
you need to tolerate--
your child's unhappiness.
It is so hard when
your child is sad.
I don't care how old-- my
kids, when they're unhappy.
You're only as happy as
you're least happy kid.
You know that.
But you've got to learn that
your child needs to be unhappy.
He needs to be frustrated.
He needs to be disappointed.
Stop trying to fix everything.
Because your child will learn as
you go back and say, you know,
this morning, you were so upset.
You were so angry at me because
I said you couldn't, whatever,
whatever.
And now look at you.
You're Fine.
You got through it.
And they have to learn that
that's going to happen in life
and they'll get through it.
Here are a few
tips, quickie tips.
How are we doing?
Are we good?
OK, a few tips for encouraging
self-reliance in your kids.
Number one, your
daily life should
be filled with rituals
that do not change.
Parents who aren't
organized or don't
have the business of
daily life organized,
they do not teach their
kids to be self-reliant.
Because knowing the
way things are done
enables your child to
do them for himself.
I always brush my
teeth after breakfast.
I can never take a bath
before I do whatever.
Your life should be
filled with rituals.
Whether it's going to
sleep at night, or the way
you have breakfast in the
morning, or how you go to bed.
A ritual-filled
life helps children
to let go and be self-reliant.
Number two, we need
to create systems
in your house that
encourage self-reliance.
So with your child's help, you
could make a pictograph if he
doesn't read-- your little
ones don't-- that has a picture
of a toothbrush, has
a picture of a jacket,
has a picture of a backpack,
and hang it by the back door.
And when you say to your
child, have you done everything
you need to do, he can
look at it himself.
You need to put things
in your house that
help them to be self-reliant.
Like have little bitty
pitchers for milk.
You shouldn't always be
pouring milk for your child.
They learn in nursery
school at two and a half
to pour their own juice.
They don't do juice anymore.
Sorry, water.
So why aren't they pouring
their own stuff at home?
Have a basket of
snacks you've already
put in little plastic bags,
keep it in the pantry,
and then say to your child,
help yourself to a snack.
So he's not always
saying, Mommy, get me.
Mommy, get me.
We want our kids
to be self-reliant.
Allow your child to
do things for himself,
and then accept the
job that he does.
If he has put his towel
up, he has hung up
his wet towel-- first
of all, glory be.
And second of all, if it's
hung up poorly, leave it.
Straighten it a
little, but leave it.
Let him know he's done it.
Except the job
that your kids do.
My husband folds our
laundry every Sunday.
I am so lucky.
We've been married 43 years.
I wash it.
He folds it.
We're in a great place.
He never quite folds my
unmentionables the way
I like them folded.
I've never told him,
oh my god, can't you
do a better job
folding my undies?
No.
When he's gone, I just quietly
refold them and I put them way.
Because I want him to
continue to fold my laundry.
Do you get what I'm saying here?
OK, same thing
goes for your kids.
Your job is to be a
consultant, not a director.
Stop saying to your kids,
do this, do this, do this,
do this.
Let your child come to
you, give him suggestions,
but stop directing your child.
We want your kid
to be self-reliant.
Teach your child how to
make decisions for herself.
Instead of saying,
it's a cold day.
Wear a jacket.
Which is what most parents say.
You could say, why don't you
go stand on the front porch
and see how it feels
before you get dressed?
You could say, you want
to look at the paper?
Let's see what the
weather forecast is.
Instead of saying,
take a jacket.
It's going to be cold.
We're teaching them to
take care of themselves.
Model how you make decisions.
Do you know that our kids never
learn how we make decisions?
Because they don't hear
us thinking about it.
Let's see, I'm going to go
here, and then after school I've
got to go there.
So I need to bring my heels in
addition to my tennis shoes.
And then I'm going to bring
something to wash my face,
because I'm going
to be-- OK, so now I
know that's what I need to do.
Or, oh, no, I'm not going
to do that because this
would happen if I do it.
Out loud.
Let your kids hear you thinking.
Because that's how
they learn to think.
No one teaches them how to
think until you show them
how to think.
And know that experience
is the very best teacher.
Repeated directions and
warnings will fall on deaf ears,
for sure.
In fact, we tell our
kids to do things
so much that they have
learned to ignore us.
We call that learned deafness.
Because it's like the
Snoopy characters.
They just, wa wa wa.
They hear it too much.
Let them learn the lesson.
If he doesn't take a jacket
to school, you pray for snow.
You've got my drift.
Do we have time to talk about
discipline for a minute?
Or not?
MALE SPEAKER: 10 minutes.
BETSY BROWN BRAUN:
We have 10 minutes.
Wow, you have 10 hours?
We could talk about discipline.
I'm just going to say a few
things about discipline.
I want to actually
talk about anger.
But first of all I want to
say, the most common call
that I get from parents is this.
My kid just doesn't
listen to me.
I hear it all the time.
And I always say, really?
Did you have his ears checked?
Hahaha.
It's not a problem of listening.
It's a problem of not obeying,
or being defiant, or being
obstinate.
But it's not a listening
problem, so let's stop saying,
my kid doesn't
listen, for starters.
The idea with
discipline is that we're
trying to teach our children.
The word discipline does
not mean punishment.
It does it mean
hurt, make feel bad,
make cry, shame, embarrass.
It means to teach, or learn.
The word discipline is from the
Latin root word disciplina--
and yes, I did
take Latin-- which
means it's about knowledge.
Like what discipline
were you in in college?
Or disciple.
Get it?
So we're trying to pound our
kids to do the right thing.
Why do I always have to
tell you to, whatever it is.
Oops, sorry.
And that's not how it works.
The way that we help our
children to cultivate
self-discipline, so the child
will do the right thing,
is by using logical consequence.
And my yellow book has a
whole chapter about this.
But the single most common
mistake that we do-- number one
is, we threaten too much.
Number two is, we
don't give children
warnings about what
we expect them to do.
And number three is, we are
bad at following through.
Warn, warn, warn, and then
we don't follow through.
So you want your kid to
get ready for school.
You're clapping your hands,
screaming at him to hurry up.
And you've got the
keys, and you're
saying, get your shoes on.
And you shake the keys.
I'm going to leave.
I'm leaving.
OK, hear me at the door.
Shake, shake, shake.
And then the child comes
running to you with his shoes,
and he says, I'm
coming, I'm coming.
And you don't leave.
And what does he learn?
He learns that he has
parents who have no cojones.
So what I would say
to you, parents,
is you need to learn to
discipline, to teach children
using logical consequences.
That means consequences that
are related to the misbehavior.
If your child is
late for school,
the punishment,
whatever that means,
is not that he doesn't go
to Disneyland on Saturday.
Or that when he hits
his brother you're
not taking away his
favorite fire truck.
Or when he doesn't
eat his food he's
not going to get a
story at bedtime.
Whatever your
consequence is, you
tell the child what you expect.
You tell them what the
consequence will be.
You expect for it to happen.
If it doesn't happen, you
impose it right then and there.
There are logical consequences,
there are natural consequences,
and there are
illogical consequences.
An illogical
consequence is when it
has nothing to do with
what's just happened.
You know what, I don't like
the way you talked to me.
No dessert tonight.
What?
What's that?
Right?
Crazy.
A natural consequence
is when you
don't have to do
anything at all.
When my son left his water
rocket out, and I said,
better put it away.
Our dog will eat it.
And he didn't, and he
came out the next morning
and there was plastic
all over the lawn.
Natural consequence.
I didn't have to do anything,
including I didn't buy him
a new water rocket.
He learned about plastic.
And by the way, if you have more
than one kid, with discipline,
it's great.
We have this thing
called ambient learning.
I made up the phrase.
Because the other two of my
kids put all their stuff away
because they didn't
want Petey dog
eating their rockets either.
How interesting is it that
my presentations are all
about parents and parenting,
and yet I'm a child development
and behavior specialist?
Kind of interesting.
The truth of the matter is
that this is about parenting.
I didn't write books
for kids to read.
Parents say, will you
autograph it to my child?
And I say, no, your child
doesn't need to read this.
You need to read this.
Having a child is not like
checking off another benchmark
on the road of life.
You got your partner, you got
your watch, you got your car,
you got your house,
and you got your child.
It doesn't work that way.
You don't just take your
child in every six months
to have a lube and oil,
or whatever that's called.
Having kids who don't come with
little instruction tags tied
to their big toe is really hard.
You've got to figure
this out for yourself.
Parenting has to be deliberate.
It has to be mindful.
And it has to be wholehearted.
Everybody blows it
every now and again.
Everybody does.
And your kids will,
and you will, too.
But if you can get
right back on the saddle
and give it your
best shot, I'm pretty
sure your kids will
be well launched.
One last thing I
want to say to you.
There is no such
thing as perfect.
Eliminate that word
from your vocabulary.
Don't ever say it.
Do not expect it.
There is excellence.
There is working hard.
But it's going to be
different for every family,
and perfection is not
what we're striving for,
unless you want to set
your child up for failure.
So that's all I want
to say about that.
I thought we would
have a few questions.
We have time?
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
BETSY BROWN BRAUN:
OK, so, did I--
Oh no, we don't have
utter silence, do we?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, I have
a six-year-old son.
BETSY BROWN BRAUN:
Ooh, satanic six.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's
get it on the--
AUDIENCE: So I have
a six-year-old son.
He's at a STEM-based
LAUSD school, brand new.
We feel very lucky,
because I hear
it's not a typical LAUSD school.
Down in Playa Vista.
And the school's
great, but they're
like overly helpful, these
eager new parents, new school.
And so they had a talent show.
We said, you're
going to try out.
You may or may not get in.
Just work hard.
Do your best.
But do you understand
what a tryout was.
We wanted to explain that
to him so he wouldn't--
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: He
was six at the time?
AUDIENCE: Six just
a few weeks ago.
So he went and did it.
Hey, he got in.
Great.
Well, now it turns
out that-- and this
is one example of what the
school does-- oh no, we
realized as parents maybe
not all the kids got in.
So is there something we
can give all the kids that
auditioned, just in case?
And we want him to learn that
not every team gets a trophy,
not every kid gets in.
But you did great, and we're
going to reward you with,
you pick out dinner tonight, or
we'll fix your favorite meal.
Because you did a great job.
You worked hard.
We'll reward you.
How do you combat the
environment giving kids
everything?
Because they want
them in the teacup.
We don't.
BETSY BROWN BRAUN:
That's double mike.
That's such a great story, and
such an important question.
And I wish-- if I had
the answer for how
we combat the
environment, just think--
I wouldn't even have
to write a book.
I'd be so popular.
I think the answer to
that is reminding you
that you are the most important
person in your kid's life.
And if you could talk about
that-- he did get chosen,
correct?
AUDIENCE: He did.
But we said, you
may or you may not.
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Yeah.
Well, that's like in soccer.
Everybody gets a trophy.
That just makes-- or
nice swing in baseball.
Sometimes you don't do as
well as you want to do.
And I think you're not going to
have trouble with that at all,
because you're aware of it.
You're being mindful about that.
But I would certainly
explain to your son,
some people didn't get it.
Sometimes that happens.
Here's what's great.
There'll be another
talent show next year.
And by the way, if
I were the parent
of the kid that didn't
get the talent show,
I'd say, well, you
didn't make it at school.
What else could we do
with that talent of yours?
Maybe he'll have his
own concert at home,
and make invitations, and
make lemonade and have--
So combating it is
going to be impossible,
but you're setting your child
up for-- you're steeling him
against peer pressure for
all kinds of good things.
With everything you feed
to him and explain to him,
he will understand.
And he will take your
attitude with him.
Thank you for that
really good question.
Was there a question over here?
Wait-- watch this.
AUDIENCE: We talked about
logical and illogical
consequences.
Can you elaborate more on--
I am totally guilty of,
you weren't being nice
today, so we're not
going to Disneyland
five days from now.
So what would be a more
logical way of handling that?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: OK.
Good for you, first of all.
So we all heard the
question, right?
Guilty, as charged.
And you're owning your
own stuff, which I love.
People ask me all the time,
because logical consequences
are hard.
You have to think
of it on the spot.
And people ask me all the
time, how do you do that?
How come you do
it so well, Bets?
I say, well, I've been
doing it for 43 years,
so I had a little experience.
But this is what
I would tell you.
What was your child doing
that you took Disneyland--
what would be an
example of that?
AUDIENCE: Hitting
a baby brother,
or not finishing his
meal before running off.
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: OK,
so not finishing the meal
before running off, or
hitting your baby brother.
Those, by the way, are
two separate chapters
in the book, food and siblings.
Just saying.
But here's what I would say.
Not finishing your meal,
that's an easy consequence.
Because the logical consequence
about that is your child
doesn't finish his meal.
He gets up.
You say, are you done?
He says, yes, and he runs off.
And you take his meal, and
you put it in the kitchen.
And a half hour later, he's
going to come and tell you
he's hungry.
Now be prepared.
It's going to be a bad night.
Just know this.
You're going to get through it.
He does not get any food.
And then in the
morning, he wakes up.
He'll get through it.
It'll be bad, but
it's only one night.
Because then he'll
have a huge pile
of pancakes in the morning.
And you're going to say
to him the next night
at dinner, remember what
happened last night?
You got up from the meal.
I took your plate away.
And you were so hungry,
and you were so unhappy.
And you cried and cried.
Boy, was that a bad night.
I think we're going to have
a better night tonight.
By the way, do read
the chapter on food,
because I have other suggestions
for that kind of thing.
Regarding siblings
hitting one another.
That's a really tough one.
I do a whole sibling thing, but
I'll tell you this about that.
For a child that hits the baby--
well, you know that's not OK.
There's a lot of
stuff that's going on,
so you have to think about
what's going on in his life.
Look, I'm cheating on him.
I had another baby.
There's all that stuff.
There's lousy local
conditions, where
he had a bad day at school.
He's tired.
He didn't have a
snack, or whatever.
I would say to
that child, you may
play in any room in
our house, except where
your baby brother is.
And I would have
gates, and I would
let him stand outside the
gate and want to come in.
Oh no, people who hit
can't come in this room.
That's one choice.
It works.
The second choice is-- how old
is your child, the older one?
He's four.
Oh, perfect.
Because then you can say when
he hits the baby-- you now
pretend you're the baby.
And you say-- you're with
the baby-- oh, Jeremy, we
don't like it when
Steven hits, do we?
We don't want to be
with someone who hits.
And you pick up Jeremy.
And you go in your room
and you close the door.
And now Jeremy is at the
door, lying on his back,
kicking your door as hard
as he can, ready to, ahh.
He's miserable.
And when he gets to this point--
[GASPING]
Because you know how kids,
when they're cr-crying,
they can't b-breathe.
When he gets to that point,
you open the door, and you say,
oh, are you ready to be with
your brother without hitting?
Oh, great, then we
can be together.
Yes?
Wait.
Yes then no.
AUDIENCE: So I think I
heard you relate boundaries,
and feeling safe, and
following through on threats.
Was I right in hearing that?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Would
you please say it
again so that I can understand
it clearly this time?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: OK.
OK, were you not listening?
AUDIENCE: I was listening--
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Kidding.
AUDIENCE: You said like four
one-liners in there, and I--
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: OK.
Here's what you need to do
with-- well, first of all,
there's a million
things you have to do.
But the common mistakes
that parents make
are that they don't
give kids warning.
And that's the one
that you missed.
Whenever you want your
child to do something,
you always go over to them
and you say, in five minutes,
it's going to be time to
put the LEGOs down and put
your shoes on.
And you don't end that
sentence with, OK?
Because you're not
asking permission.
You say, did you
hear what I said?
Do you copy, Red Rider?
Whatever you want to
say, something that he
will then answer you and
say, yes or no, or whatever.
Then you come back
in five minutes,
and you say, and now
it's time-- sorry--
now it's time to
put your LEGOs down.
And if he makes a
motion towards that--
because it's really hard
to stop doing something
you like to do and
then do something else.
Even if you love your bath, you
really love your LEGOs, too.
OK, so if he makes a
motion, you help him.
Come on, let's save these LEGOs.
You can do it again
in the morning.
We'll put a sign on it.
Don't touch, da, da, da, da, da.
And then you go in and
use-- if he doesn't
make a motion towards doing
what you say-- if you come
to your bath now-- get ready
for a logical consequence--
if you come to
your bath now, then
we will have time for two books.
Because children--
ritual-- children
always have two books, not five.
One for each hand.
Two.
Why do you have two?
So you can take one away.
OK?
You get two books.
So if you come now,
you'll have two books.
If you don't--
logical consequence--
we won't have time for two.
We'll have only one.
OK,
So we warn.
We state what the threat is.
And then when he
doesn't come you say,
OK, I guess we're
only having one book.
Follow through.
AUDIENCE: So following
through on the threat
is enforcing the boundary?
BETSY BROWN BRAUN: Absolutely.
And why would you ever threaten
with something you can't do?
Don't ever threaten
with something
you don't want to
do when you've been
waiting to go to the beach.
You say, OK, if you
don't brush your teeth,
we're not going to the beach.
Which would be ridiculous.
And you've been
wanting to go all week.
Why would you say that?
Get it?
You'll learn it.
I promise.
Read my books.
Enjoy.
Thanks for coming.
See you another time.
[APPLAUSE]